G like Jim carries that way. Like you just follow him.
He's so funny because he makes such a choice and commits to it. Yeah. Yeah.
There was one. I'm never going to remember this,
but he did the Jim Carrey thing.
I watched the clip of him doing the do not go in there. Oh yeah.
And I was thinking about like on a page that is just not funny at
all. I know. I know him doing it is the funniest thing. Carrie is.
I, I don't,
I don't understand how I can't understand how good he
is. Yeah. At doing the most ridiculous. Yeah.
And it's funny. I it's so hard
to do that. It's so hard to commit that much and still be funny. Yeah.
I think we talked about your career the last time. Oh, we did. We did.
We did love Jim Carrey so much. Yeah. I do love him so much.
What's that movie where there's a, there's one movie where a guy,
this guy, dude, I know movies. I'll help you out. All right, bro.
I just know this guy opens, it, opens the door to something and he goes,
Oh, any faints Jim carried? No, it's not Jim Carey. I put on my Instagram,
once this guy falls down and I that's
all I know. Wow.
And all I remember is the manager at the comedy store thinks it's funny and
remembers the movie. I want to do it. That's a bad story. Yeah.
I'm going to text him. You know what I mean? Yeah.
That story is like really bad. Yeah. It doesn't even have a middle.
You know what I know.
I know it literally has only a beginning and a vague one. I'm going to,
what was the movie?
Where the guy I'm going to text him right now?
Falls down and Oh man.
I can't remember how to describe it. And it was so funny eighties.
Does he need to know it was an eighties movie. Yeah. Eighties movie to remember,
when we were watching vice versa, not vice versa. What was the one?
Was it vice versa? We were watching it with dad when we were kids.
And I was like, this is so eighties. And dad was like, yes,
exaggerate. Don't know how to spell it. Oh wow. I do.
But I don't want to exaggerate, you know? Um, yeah, true.
And he said confused. He said,
what's a DS that's and we were like
eighties. Yeah. the word and
time period of the movie. And he was like, what's that? So dad and we were like,
what's wrong with your brain? Yeah. You know what I mean? So it went,
it was like, so eighties, we were, he said something right.
Or the movie was so eighties or the movie was so eighties. And I said, you said,
Oh eighties. And you were like, I know. Yeah. So eighties.
And he goes like that and he was like, acting like, huh? Cool. Yeah.
And then he was like, what's right. What's uh, Oh yeah.
He said what's a D yes. And we were like,
nothing like no eighties. And he, and then he goes, Oh, Oh.
And then we were like, do you get what we're saying? And he said,
what's a T yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. And we were like, eighties, like the year.
Yeah. Fix your brain. Yeah. And we, and now we always say what's D yeah.
We always say also to not, it was so 80.
I know the movie was so eighties do the work of connecting things, right?
Yeah. That is not him though. Yeah. That's so him, what's a D so the zoo,
but I love, uh, having that. I love,
you never know when some going to like, be with you for the rest.
I always talk about this. I love this.
You never know some going to be with you for the rest of your life.
And then it happens. And then you'll always talk about it. For sure.
I love those moments because you never know they're going to happen.
And now you have it with you for the garden. And it's a happy accident.
I have the worst memory, but there's like a handful of things like that,
that I remember, like they remembered happened. He remembered it.
He just texted me back, dude. It's the movie cuffs, dude. Cuffs.
Okay. Cuffs, starring Christian Slater.
I think of that movie a lot,
because there's a play on words that he says in that movie. And it's, you know,
that expression things to people to see things, to do people,
to see, you know, the expression. Oh no. He says,
Oh yes, yes, yes, yes. People to do yes. Things to see, like,
he's gonna a lot of people. You know what I mean? Like yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
That's. Which is the raddest thing. That is the raddest thing. Oh, okay.
I gotta find this video. Cause this is the greatest,
greatest example of what we're talking about. Jim Carey does, right?
This is the greatest example of, of this. Well, that's shot. So amazing.
This is so funny.
And this guy went for it and I couldn't believe I get to go to find it.
I don't know. I mean, you said you could find everything on the internet. Oh,
so you're putting me now. Yeah. We'll put in maybe cuffs, something specific.
Like movie guy falls down. Pratfall opens door. Coughs.
The guy opens the door and he gets, Oh wait, uh, fall down.
No, that's not it. Oh, he's he was look at Christian Slater, dude.
This is that. That's it. This is going to be it. Is this it?
No, that's not it. Oh, Whoa. So eighties. Wow. I mean,
she'll be already re ready with a gun faster. Yeah.
I'm sure it was cuffs. Yeah. He said it was cuffs. I'm looking,
I'm looking. I'm low. This movie's amazing. I'm watching this tonight.
I got to find this video before we are done. Okay. Prep. Fall.
Proud to watch this scene from cuffs. How do you spell?
Pratfall just the way you think it is T one T but,
but Chris Pratt is a thing now. And now I can do that. It's just one
labeled the prep. That's a line. I think of all the time.
Rick is your face and the original office.
I guess I could look up the cast here and find a guy that would, that did it.
I am db.com. What are you?
The cost?
Is that it? Oh, wow. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay. it. He'll tell you that.
It's hilarious. Like cuffs get ready to Larry is yep. Okay. Okay.
I got it. I got it. If it's a crystal, Leah,
like you posted this cause you love it. Well, let's just put up 11.
Don't play it. I want it. We had this. Yeah, I think this is it. Okay.
This is so, I mean, how many hilarious do reactions? Can there be in cuffs?
Wow. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Away away. When I saw that,
I got to see it. When I saw this, this.
You would die at that. You must've.
Almost died. This was a choice.
First of all,
the fact that the clip is 11 seconds is just that thought. Yeah,
this is the choice. I'm going to make the
Boulder balls. You have to have, those are Mondo. Not the star, by the way.
He's the guy in it, right? Yeah. I mean,
imagine being the director being like, you don't know what he's going to do.
Yeah. And you'd have to take the rest of the day off because you're like,
my movie's going to be a masterpiece now. Unbelievable. So,
um, all right, so I'm gonna play it again. And then,
and then for the fact that it's to make it funny should thank her.
That's your banker.
Oh dude. That is a genius thing to do. I mean, he keeps his arms up.
Why is this? Why do his arms go up? Why do his arms go up?
Wow. That's actually.
Funny. I can't even laugh at it. I know I am. You're a genius.
I feel like if Jim Carrey saw that, he'd be like, Oh wow, that's great. Yeah,
for sure. Yeah. We should show him.
Almost knocked into the other guy to mad. Was the other actor. I know, I know.
This is going to be my, yeah. I thought it was really my scene. You know?
That was your banker. Chris gin. Slater's Hey, I know, dude.
Chris has laid his hair is the most ruling us
there ever was in 1992. Yeah. man.
So funny. All right.